Speaker 1: So yesterday there was a press
briefing from Nashville PD after the shooting
at the Covenant School, this horrible event
in which six people were killed and the shooter
also died and a parent was actually able to
get on air, which was fantastic.
And as The Daily Beast writes, a mother visiting
Nashville took to the Fox News airwaves to
call out the country's lack of gun safety
as yet another mass shooting unfolded at a
Nashville school.
This was as reporters and crews were waiting
for a police press conference to start.
The woman has been identified by local reporters
as Ashby Beasley, who herself survived the
July four parade in Highland Park, Illinois,
and was a block away from the Covenant School
yesterday.
Here she is jumping in.
And this is.
Take a listen.
Speaker 2: She was tired of covering this.
Aren't you guys tired of being here and having
to cover all of these mass shootings?
I'm from Highland Park.
Speaker 1: The audio briefly cuts out, but
then it comes back.
Speaker 2: Family vacation with my son visiting
my sister in law.
I have been lobbying in DC since we survived
a mass shooting in July.
I have met with over 130 lawmakers.
How is this still happening?
How are our children still dying?
And why are we failing them?
Gun violence is the number one killer of children
and teens.
It has overtaken cars.
Assault weapons are contributing to the border
crisis and fentanyl.
We are arming cartels with our guns and our
guns.
Loose gun laws.
And these shootings and these mass shootings
will continue to happen until our lawmakers
step up and have gun safety legislation.
Speaker 1: Yeah, but instead, they want to
pass laws about critical race theory books
that need to be banned.
Art that needs to be banned.
History that can't be taught.
Sex education that can't be taught.
They want to do everything other than actually
deal with what is at issue here.
Speaker 2: I'm pretty sure this was an unsecured
weapon that this teenager got a hold up.
We can't even pass gun safe storage laws in
this country to protect kids from getting
a hold of weapons that they shoot each other
when.
Speaker 3: All right.
So we're going to break away there because
that reporter who is using that camera is
obviously setting up to do a live report there.
But the woman said it quite simply.
Aren't you tired of this?
Yes, we are tired of this.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Of course, most of Fox News disagrees
with what needs to be done in order to try
to resolve the situation.
Good for her.
Sounds weird to say right place, right time,
because the right place is not really being
a block away from a shooting that's extremely
dangerous.
But the right place, right time to at least
get that out on national television and absolutely
good for her.
They want to ban all sorts of stuff, but it's
all the wrong things and we're going to continue
covering it.
We'll take a break and be back with plenty
more right after this